Amy Schumer is getting real about her  first time revealing to Marie Claire  that the experience wasn't consensual  quote I didn't think about it until I  started reading my journal again I wrote  about it almost like a throwaway it was  like and then I looked down and realized  he was inside of me he was saying I'm so  sorry and I can't believe I did this the  comedian was going through her old  journals while riding her upcoming book  of essays the girl with the lower back  tattoo Amy lost her virginity when she  was 17 and tells the magazine she has no  interest in punishing the guy now quote  this was 17 years ago there are justice  so many factors